on l'a dit est la grand-mère qui l'a dit
à son voisin le voisin labouchère
labouchère à son gamin 100 gamins qui
tètent phone n'a rien eu de plus urgent
que de le dire à l'école à son voisin
pierre jean
lémance de clémence a pris d
vacances paiement se fait plus rien
clément se blesse c'est comme
enfance
clémence va bien
ça semble ad'abord étrange on
s'interrogeait un peu sur ceux qui
parfois dérange la raison de certains
vieux dit quelques mauvaises chutes
avait pu l'handicapé ou encore une
dispute avec ce brave honoré
clémence de clémence à prix d'or
et vacances clémence ne fait plus rien
comment ce clip c'est comme mon enfance
clémence va mieux
puis on a pris par son gendre qui ne
s'est rien passé mais simplement qu'à
l'entendre elle en avait fait à ceignac
ayant toutes ses jambes elle reste dans
son fauteuil un peu de malice flambe
parfois mort de son deuil
clémence e clémence a pris des vacances
clémence ne fait plus rien
clémence anglais c'est comment
enfance
clément amiens
honoré c'est bien dommage je dois tout
faire à la maison la cuisine et le
ménage le linge et les commissions quand
il essaie de lui dire de coudre un
bouton perdu elle répond dans un sourire
rare chez tient à ces mesures
les manceaux clémence a pris des
vacances
clément se veut sérieux
clément se fait pour être mon enfance e
clémence va bien
c'est la maîtresse d'école qui l'a dit
aux pharmaciens et heymans est devenue
folle paraît qu'elle ne fait plus rien
mais selon la petite guerre dans
l'histoire du fort et pas qu'elle ne
veuille mes affaires mais n'en est aucun
remords
les manceaux clémence a pris des
vacances des manceaux ne ferait mieux
clermont se demande comment
enfance
les mauves amiens
je suis de bon voisinage on le salue
couramment loin de moi l'idée peu sage
d'inquiéter les braves gens elle est
grand mère commence dream et par les
trois la maladie de clémence pourrait
bien s'étendre là
toutes les clément se prendrait des
vacances qu'elle ne ferait pour rien
toutes les clés comment
c'est bien
toutes les clément se prendre des
vacances
elle ne ferait plus rien
raymond ces commandes enfants se
reporteraient
enfin